[Music]
in first-born for the wind news
submitted by the first comment a new
sign a little a new study claims that
the second born children are more likely
to be troublemakers really old wife's no
they always seem like the first one is a
good one in the second second born
I'm third does that mean those abortion
before me didn't you say there was I'm
the firstborn that I know of I'm a
troublemaker so there could have they
could have gone really good you know why
they're the most troublesome was because
the first kid always gets the most love
and attention and when the second one
comes out they're like I already gave it
to this know as soon as they're newborns
I've heard parents say like this one
cries all the time like this one gives
me so much like [ __ ] know what's the
same thing they just don't remember how
bad it was on the first time because you
were so in love with your first kid
correct oh really
that's the reason why yep so they're not
so that's not even true then what was oh
so if you give them the same amount of
love as you did the first with the first
baby then you should have a fine baby
really but they're probably like the
second time that comes around they're
like my mom said to you not only that
but then also like once by the time the
second one comes around most parents are
like oh they're playing together they
that's what Casey was saying like in his
home he's like yeah I could see how that
happened because his brother was more
troublesome than he was and that's
because those five years before his
brother came along his Casey got most of
the attention if Casey was born his mom
would like be really interactive with
him and trying to read with him or play
with him or do something but then once
his brother came along they were like oh
they have each other to play with and so
the brother didn't get as much attention
just like with a second dog too you have
the first dog you give all that love to
him and you bring the second one around
so they could play with the other one
and then you're like you [ __ ]
are good
I like the second one more because it's
newer so I won't pollute the second one
more than like the first thing your old
that's coldest [ __ ] yeah Oh Casey's mom
was saying that Casey's brother just out
the womb was already just picky but we
didn't know that different temperament
and everything I mean who knows so what
does that mean like the fifth kid is a
convict for sure six kids just to see
what happens yeah what happens to the
third and fourth
how come it's only one and two my mom
said none of us were bad if I was a
parent like a first kid you love it
second kid you're like and then the
third kid you're like alright I'm ready
to do this again
so like this like I don't know the one
in the middle is like yeah he actually
do you like this though if you go to my
house and you go into this little thing
beneath the sink there's a bunch of
photo albums right there's about six
binders or so okay six binders and if
you split them in half one is mine what
is my brothers now if you split them in
half my brothers bistek is this big mine
is this big oh you're the second one I
was forgetting yes I'll be second time
yeah imma go but that's normal though
cuz of the first one right out of film
that's what pictures but in the second
one they're typically at a more busier
point in life I was like I'll be rude to
her now I was lightweight seller when I
got old and I saw the photo album I only
had one they're older they're busier
beardy had the excitement with the first
one you're all not ready to celebrate
and then film not really expensive yeah
yeah so this study that came out in July
that's the excuse I make yep oh yeah
you're second yeah I have less pictures
that he'll expect in July is titled
birth order and delinquency and it
looked at rates of violent crime and
school suspensions for a thousand so
much poison in Denmark and Florida and
so the reason why they picked water in
Florida is because well ii must spell
[ __ ] up places in the world
yeah exactly what I mean like oh okay I
see they can have a more with like more
a bigger sample size I like that I like
that so what they found is and also they
focused on boys because statistically
boys get into trouble anger was horrible
I mean with the cops and so they found
that with families of two or more
children this when a second boy a second
born boy was 20 to 40% more likely to be
disciplined in school and to enter into
the criminal justice system than the
oldest child
yes 20% more likely than the oldest
child that makes a lot more sense well
I'm glad I know this now so we have our
second kid we can ignore tyke it
completely yep talking buddies in the
middle like no it's a door Wyatt no
black or [ __ ] white no Griffin I
shouldn't be so funny like the second
kick comes out and then like we just I
give all that kid Levitt Titan comes
around why don't you just shut the [ __ ]
up always with your mouth open drooling
all over the place [ __ ] come here by
[Laughter]
Khalil Julia or Jimmy I like Arabic
names yeah Julio's not Arabic is black
wait how are you like when you guys have
the second kid like how are you gonna
are you gonna like be a little different
or like what if it happen or do you just
name your kid like Steve yeah I mean
just give him a regular ass [ __ ] you say
there's a tiger that'd be hilarious no
it's like like like oh it might not even
have anything to do with how y'all
raised it cuz like what if your kid
comes out and just beats your ass like
because it's the second child oh that's
impossible where we repeating is
hospital is the nickname your game you
get Pekka oo3 story he is a second kid's
name pony
cuz tortilla and rice jack is not
Mexican yeah oh oh no yeah but so the
scientists they were also pointing out
another thing which was that the
firstborns their role models are adults
because they don't have anyway yeah
and so the second-born their only other
roman or the only role models that they
look up to is their the oldest child is
like a two year old resolution you just
like the movie frozen split those
[ __ ] up in two separate rooms there
you go so they never see each other I
think it's a scene through the to a
[ __ ] door you should see it I've
never seen it either but that's not like
a great idea
yeah I also just kind of want to see
what's gonna happen he's gonna [ __ ]
passing notes to each other they don't
know what the [ __ ] they look like jail
and then when I finally let them meet
each other when they're sixteen I'm
gonna put it on YouTube yeah like that
oh yeah that'd be cool they'll be good
also would all be viral I would click on
that I never know what their sibling
looks like I me my sleeping for 16 years
I've been living in a cage 18 year old
meet siblings meet for the first time
and they meet in a room and they have to
battle each other today and they've been
yeah after the death to fight for the
pants love yeah yeah yeah what [ __ ]
tonight's me depending on who wins they
will get a hug and a kiss yes I like
these rules and I'm gonna be a great
father
I should not have children yeah I'm like
split them up and they make a fight
sometimes I'll be talking about like oh
you know soon I'll be having kids in a
few years and stuff like that then I
think like how much they're gonna piss
me off and I start getting angry exist
yet we'll just yell yeah but you're
imagining a fight already that doesn't
even happen exactly no you [ __ ]
[ __ ] she goes you know one day we'll
be we'll have kids and stuff like that
like oh you know remember how you were a
kid as like I know I wish my kid would I
[ __ ] suck the [ __ ] at a little
[ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] dare you [ __ ] and
he's not even existing it yeah so I want
to preemptively spanking him in my head
you
you just made me dread the day that I
have a child and my child talks back to
me cuz like I'm not gonna know what to
do oh I can't wait til they talk back I
don't even like my brain just like cuts
out trying to think about how I would
respond what would you guys do I could
talk back to you I will [ __ ] dig a
hole in their backyard and in bury them
up to his neck and then leave them there
for maybe two hours until he learns to
not do that again you know it's crazy I
can't picture taiko older so I picture
him like with the body still drooling on
himself at the age of 20 issues bodies
all developed I can't even picture him
with teeth actually yeah I can't I can't
picture speaking we have the next kid
yeah I always wonder like is it gonna
feel like the first kid all over again
cuz it's been 10 years since the last
gonna feel like the first two do you
think I'm gonna feel like I wonder if
it's gonna feel like it's a first kid
all over again cuz I forgot everything
from its gonna feel you having the first
200 brand-new something and looking at
this and I'm like I feel like maybe the
second the second kid would be like the
first kid and then we won't have this
problem I want my kid to look at me in
one day I say dad [ __ ] hurt you and
I'm like master teenage closet you
[ __ ] [ __ ] child are you going to
everyone it's gonna be like a mr. and
mrs. Smith house I don't you know why
our family so pork as I invested all the
money in it
oh [ __ ] suit up kid I didn't [ __ ]
medieval armor comes out in here yes
that would duel and I specifically had
to not work out ever so he's gonna be
weakest [ __ ]
like your child one day talking back to
you and you're just like all right
square up your kids just like white like
square from about to be dressed yeah oh
god damn that's the kind of fantasies
you have I was thinking the other day if
I have a daughter that I'm gonna build
like a freakin cardboard box castle with
her and it we're gonna have pretend like
[ __ ] dragons and princesses you doing
like what you're brainwashing her
already to like know that jamali is real
genius is already really I think you
know the princess of I picture the
cardboard castle but I'm a dope-ass meal
he's all blood yeah my mom would do she
would beat my [ __ ] ass and maybe the
best dinner ever
that's what name experience for your
child yep I love my mom you know what I
feel like that would make you appreciate
the food more you know because you know
why you appreciate the food more because
it's hard to taste it when you're crying
[Music]
you